[Music]
have been rumors out about the new Call
of Duty is going to be you know kind of
revealed sometime soonish in the coming
weeks from sledgehammer games their turn
in that three studio rotation for call
of duty games but also like we just said
battlefront two is focusing more boots
on the ground from the Empire's
perspective it's also one of the writers
from spec ops the line very very good
game kind of took a look at what it like
shoot what it means to kind of be doing
screwed up stuff because you're being
told to in war but what Williams is also
writing battlefront two with a few other
people at EA motive but we figured it'd
be a good time because of all this to
talk about our favorite war games our
favorite games about war not necessarily
like spec ops at critique it but
sometimes there's fun like I don't know
red alert 2 is one of my favorite games
and that's a really dumb look at war
it's like you have Yuri's like in the
expansion yuri's revenge you have this
this faction that kind of has like brain
control [ __ ] and then you have Tanya you
can have an army of Tanya's crawling
across with c4 is blowing up base but uh
we already mentioned I want to talk
about spec ops the line quick because we
talked about so much if you guys all
played it no but I watched Chris waters
wonderful video review this morning i
miss that guy yeah he knows how to write
a beautiful script yeah it's uh it's a
really cool game we to pimp something
that Jake Decker and I are doing our
next episode of reboot the show we've
been working on is about war in games
and kind of games that portray it well
games that critique what it means to be
playing a soldier in a game and whether
it should be fun and I mean how they
make war games fun in general but also
uh yeah we talked a lot about spec ops
and this is an important game in that i
really don't i know the statute of
limitations probably lifted but i still
am hesitant to generation old i know but
i'm still hesitant to spoil this if
you're watching now and you haven't
played it just because the ending is
super integral to the game the why it's
important i mean yeah if not boiling it
it's cool it it it makes you actually
it's kind of the Bioshock of war games
almost it examines what you're doing and
why you're doing in how you're doing
what you're told and how you factor into
like screwed up things that are really
happening just by the fact that it's a
game and it's just a fun game but then
you know like
I call you out for thinking that but
it's uh it's a really a game like I said
first same writer as battlefront tues
campaign one of them Walt Williams so
that's this from developer Yeager but uh
Kelly you said you've you played this I
mean use you've said most of the things
like yes don't spoil anything yeah i
just i like i like a an examination of
why we find this sort of thing fun I
mean I I grew up playing shooters which
is a weird sentence um and it's
important to reflect I think I think
it's important to reflect on why you
enjoy that sort of thing and it was
important for me sorry he was just doing
a really realistic thing oh there's yeah
I was like that is super weird did you
see that we were talking about Mitch
Dyer writing battlefront and then in
this video review in the lobby was Chris
waters and Mitch Dyer hey that's weird
uh yes but anyway we are yeah like I
said if you get the chance on Sunday go
check out reboot 3pm we talk more about
spec ops but it's also one last thing
it's kind of based around Apocalypse Now
or heart of darkness kind of looking it
going down this like long river to
Colonel Kurtz or whatever this a wall
general uh anyway Kelly wants how about
modern warfare that for I really want to
talk about modern warfare um a game that
we all hate not a show hi i love this
game uh yeah i mean i played modern
warfare remastered obviously and i think
it's aged really well my favorite
mission is and I don't care about
spoiling this because not the end is
when you have to save the helicopter
pilot the helicopters crashed and i
think it's called charlie don't surf is
it the same one is charlie don't surf
the one before i think it is this is
charlie don't surf right here so yeah
you might write so it's the one right
before you have to save her and there's
a time limit and no matter how quickly
you do it you you get nuked anyway you
die anyway and when i first played this
game that was it I hadn't really played
a game where like I couldn't succeed um
and it was I just SAT there and thought
about it for a really long time I
remember and when I played it again I
having come off of you know black ops 3
or even infinite warfare where you're
like super
powered you can do anything you're
moving really quickly you go to modern
warfare and you're moving your
clambering over [ __ ] and like you are
getting bombed out and you have to like
really when you have to really try
especially if you're playing on hard
endure veteran and I just liked that
slow down I like going back to something
that felt more human than being able to
wall run and jump jet pack out of
whatever situation like I you can't jet
pack out of this you know you to segue
actually you just remind me of this
mission but where I was going to go into
was again not by any means realistic but
like Halo Reach had that same ending
mm-hmm and as a huge halo fan playing
that game it was the first time where uh
you know you you play as master chief or
even arbiter just he's really
overpowered super soldiers and that game
you had a squad you had people that
weren't just generic scripted you know
grunts from aliens who just had the same
like two three lines these are people
who were like sacrificing their lives
like for you and one by one like the
last few few hours that game were like
as against someone who's playing that
series was like this is uncomfortable in
a good way and yeah it ended you know
with you basically dying like you turned
into like a horde mode or zombies even
right like you're just you're you know
the yet like the ending right yeah kinda
guy and here it is right here your noble
seven and your this measure starts to
crack more and more yeah showing a
Katherine Halsey the scientist that's
kind of in charge of Spartan program and
you're transporting Cortana to the
dropship to give to you find out later
master chiefest takes place right before
they do the slipspace jump the random
one which you're not supposed to do
because you have no idea where in the
universe or the galaxy i'll end up but
they end up at halo and then pillow of
autumn mission starts from halo combat
evolved and there's that easter egg if
in the cutscene if you hold the right
the stick to the right you can look over
and see Master Chief finish cry oh
really yeah it's really cool this game
is fantastic again I keep mentioning it
but it's almost like that Saving Private
Ryan is a small squad with personalities
so when someone dies you feel it all the
more
the vin diesel scene which sucks and Sam
hi Ryan or forget what's the the one on
one scene with a knife of the stabbing
that part's always tough to watch but
this game gets pretty emotional it's
really impressive that you know the
whole time you're gonna lose in the end
but it's still fun throughout yeah and
some and some people on your squad like
didn't necessarily die very heroic right
they would just be like a sniper shot
from you know a jackal like geez like he
just you know it left you uh with very
abrupt like ways of dying and use it was
uncomfortable yeah yeah going back to
modern warfare really quickly there's an
achievement for it's like super early on
the game but if there you're like in a
stairwell and I forget what level it is
but um you can get an achievement for
like saving this kid because like a an
enemy will just come in like stab him
and I didn't I did it and I didn't even
know there's an achievement for it like
I had forgotten and um I don't know what
about it like everybody in your squad
has a name and I know what about it like
stuck with me like the fact that I saved
him on accident and I was like oh wow he
could have easily died and he's not a
real person but like that happens in
real life all the time I don't know what
it was it just really messed me up yes I
was mentioning also the no Russian
mission from modern warfare 2 with that
I yeah that was a bhushan Ryu cat non
twitch saying are you guys gonna talk
about modern warfare 2 is level no
Russian that was surreal if you don't
know that's the one where you kind of
you don't have to start opening up fire
but you're in the airport and you're
you're you're like undercover with these
Russians you start just shooting
civilians in the airport and you don't
actually have to but they kind of
heavily incurred not encourage you but
yeah you can see it right here but they
kind of heavily say and then it's kind
of like scary this is also what
2008-2009 yeah like what tough that I
forget how it's oh my god it's so
upsetting now that's actually one thing
about modern warfare again we talked a
lot about that i'll reboot this weekend
it's it was weird my brother did three
tours in Iraq with the Marines and then
two in Afghanistan and as opposed to the
world war two games that called video is
done modern warfare came along and then
it's fictional kind of combines Cold War
fears of nukes and Russia being the
enemy with terrorism and
you know like insurgents from the Middle
East that you always saw in CNN but it
was weird to be playing a game
portraying a conflict that was currently
happening mm-hmm and that was kind of
weird I mean that was the first time I
felt uncomfortable but then yeah this
came along as what the [ __ ] is going on
that is I don't think they pulled that
off at all no it's oh so uncomfortable I
mean I mean if you were around at that
time it was so controversial they like
you can opt not to play it yeah like
couldn't sell it in like Germany or
something um some some European country
was like nah like [ __ ] off with that
mm-hmm um yeah it is a very weird ship
because I mean you start out playing
like like I personally started out on
like doom and quake and then I played
like World War two shooters and then you
get into this sort of thing which is
like you said like a real conflict that
is happening and you see you know the
insurgents killer president and it's
like it's much more real because it's
not as distant as something like World
War to World War two was always like
glorified um was also like kind of more
black and white I guess good versus evil
well yeah it's very easy to be like we
all know the Nazis are evil it's like
fun but yeah there's much more you feel
bad I'm good yeah I mean I love that I
love modern warfare I love that game
yeah there's also it also has those dumb
military like stay frosty Marines things
that I'm like playing a remastered and
being like oh yeah I forgot one we all
thought that was cool if you're playing
Mass Effect Andromeda there's a classic
when I way out of the ice planet stay
extra frosty uh yeah to crawl out of
this depressing hole and also out of
that awful bit of writing Pete you want
to match something a little more you
could it's not getting us Mike yes uh
final fancy tactics is a game about war
obviously it's sort of like a medieval
fantasy sort of thing so it's not war
the way we've been talking about wars
right but what it deals with is sort of
like you know who controls the history
books after a conflict right usually the
people who win but you know when you
when you do that you sort of lose touch
of all the actual events that happen so
this game actually shows you the events
as they occurred versus as how history
remembers them in this world and the
things that sort of lead to a certain
person winning and then rewriting the
history books has a lot to do with like
class warfare has a lot to do with how
religion sort of inspires people to do
things to cause Wars and you know
something like that and this game is a
little bit hard to follow because
especially the the naming of a lot of
characters and places and events is very
rapid and it's very odd you have
characters named jeff gary on delita
like things that just sound really
really strange but so you may have to
play this game a few times to really get
everything but it's a really curious
examination of the manipulation of
people events and information around war
I mean like in strategy games like this
kind of top-down isometric or I mean I
wanted to talk about ex-con to really
briefly because that's the game I always
try to talk about when I gets a chance
but I'm already talked about it once
yeah I know but I'm gonna again we I
always get kind of attached two
characters and games like this when I
know like all their abilities in there I
don't know like fire emblem comes to
mind too but I know what how they play
into my squad my team overall do you get
the sense from that you actually get
attachments these characters or they
kind of just these veneers well you do I
mean there are some characters that can
never die permanently but most of the
characters in your party will which
includes your starting cast and some
characters that you pick up throughout
the story that are like you know like
special characters right like one off
classes and stuff like that but you can
even you know dismiss troops and and
stuff like that if you need to make room
in your party and these characters they
all have these like lines that they give
where they feel like what I'm not good
enough like I'm so sorry I didn't mean
to let you down like you're really going
to cast me aside and and so maybe even
if they're not dying even if you're just
shuffling them around you can feel bad
for them your guts are hanging out of
your stomach clearly you're not good
enough get out of here Joe died no just
kidding I wouldn't do that yeah this is
a if you consider this sort of like
aspects of [ __ ] so I sort of aspects of
war that drive something like Game of
Thrones because there is kind of like an
overarching more behind all of that
apart from you know the wall and all
that [ __ ] but this this game is really
good in that sort of vein and really
just kind of keeps you guessing from
beginning to end in terms
like who's really in control and who is
the one who has the most at stake at war
even tell me to play this for a long
time we had been tell a lot of people I
should yeah it's the best way to play
this on time damn there's like two
sequels that came out tactics advance
and Texas advanced to a 2 is on gb
advanced but don't around es but don't
play those play this one either the
PlayStation class text version on your
Vita PSP ps3 or you can also do the war
or the lions which is sort of like an
updated version that is on iOS PSP and
PS Vita cool um I also Robbie already
talked about halo reach a little bit
when we're talking about battlefront but
yeah there are a couple other standouts
that actually kind of take a cool little
world this war of mine is more focus on
the civilians and how they're affected
it's like an Eastern European conflict
but you have to just survive in these uh
yeah [ __ ] the word there you can you see
on their back but you are you are
civilians surviving in this Eastern
European conflict and you essentially
every time you play it's kind of a
procedural in terms of how long you'll
tape you have to just survive until a
ceasefire is called which is completely
out of your control and you're just kind
of doing kind of you see a fallout
shelter perspective on this lot darker
than fallout shelter though you know the
I think the something the children is
the dlc for it and it comes in Judy's
kids into it you have to kind of take
care of them as well but yeah you have
to decide who your enemies are yeah who
I don't know it's it's the who your
enemies are and who your teammates are
and how this all factors into how the
civilians get affected because it's you
know like kind of talking about how this
is there or the way they perceive that
even though they weren't fighting in the
overall conflict it's it's also just
maybe not fun but it's also really
rewarding managing these teams like kind
of you're talking about Final Fantasy
Tactics err i guess x come to you get
attached to these characters throughout
each playthrough and you're like ok this
person is good at lock picking or
cooking this person is useful for that
but then you start seeing them on a more
emotional level and it's pretty
rewarding I suggest trying it out it was
the PlayStation Plus free game
last month or that's sorry like three
months ago actually they asked worth
playing if you haven't any others that
you want to mention that I didn't yes
that reminded me um I want to talk about
papers please a little bit um sorry John
Luke for not prepping you on that uh but
yeah something that's not about actually
fighting in the war and it's also
Eastern European well like a fake
Eastern European country papers please
if you aren't familiar with it you have
to kind of look at people's documents
and either let them into like let them
across the border or deny them and if
you get I almost forget how it works but
I just remember being like haunted by
the sound effects cuz like you can hear
like I don't know it's like very simple
and and it sounds like we're glad you
and stuff yeah but like the act of
deciding who you let in yeah I probably
tough because in the beginning it's just
about making sure that like okay I need
to have these pieces of information yeah
they have these pieces of information so
they're good to go but then people come
up and admit to you that like I don't
have my documents but I'm escaping an
abusive husband exactly i need to get
across the border here's like a thousand
dollars please please let me across and
you can do that but you might get caught
you don't want to get here or voiding
getting caught and because you are also
making a like a pittance to support your
family and you have to like pay your
bills and it gets really emotional when
people are like please just please let
me in and you have to like yeah like you
can see here your kind of verifying that
they are from where they say they are
and it's so simple and it seems like a a
game about doing a menial task would be
boring but it's I couldn't stop playing
it when it came out came out like what
2012-2013 yeah something around then
yeah it's worth checking out it's it's
easy to play and kind of like bite-size
chunks too but it's kind of interesting
to think that which seems to be seems to
be the most tedious and boring job you
know like I just think of like a guy at
the airport like just checking your your
your stuff your passport the games last
year where you're like a customer
service rep I get this call every day
yeah
moral implications but still kind of a
similar thing but yeah so I those kind
of a few themes we want to talk about
whether they were just fun games or ten
kind of took a cool look at war again on
Sunday we have something going up about
how games portray war and how they might
be able to do better based on some of
these games bus and was a bus bush
machine bhushan the opening normandy
beach for frontline metal honor and was
one I want to say just because like it
was I think was like the first time
we're like I had my parents watch me
play it and they both were like wow
video games are kind of cool or like you
know pretty intense what are you playing
yeah well that was the one thing but
like it was the first time but she was
like I remember my mom was like wow
that's pretty heavy I was like I think
allied assault with the first normandy
beach invasion in a game and then
frontline came along if i'm not mistaken
a light is always on pc marijuana
frontlines normandy on the Atari 2600
was pretty good what i have the opposite
thing where my dad was like hey check
this game out and we played it and it
was intense yeah oh yeah good cogs that
that game we were talking that coming it
becomes like a James Bond movie halfway
through this undercover agent going into
German u-boats and sneaking behind enemy
lines and go into that dinner party
where you have to be stealthy a little
bit but i guess the stealths kind of
rudimentary in hindsight man i forgot
the entire game clearly she felt about
taking food on people's plates yeah lip
and eye drops into people you don't like
their wine not that i do that in real
life anyway yeah let us know if we
forgot to mention any uh like I said
with a call of duty announcement
supposedly coming soon we'll know more
about that from sledgehammer games
battlefront two is focusing more on its
campaign this time around with a couple
of writers who have kind of had
experience and like what spec ops the
line and yet we're excited for those so
uh and Dawn of War I guess that's more
fantasy war but an RTS game they'll
release the next week our review will be
up soonish tomorrow tomorrow if you're
watching this live it'll be tomorrow
April twentieth length sorry just
kidding exactly 420 what what did you do
what is that nothing I don't do anything
right let us know in the comments thanks
you
[Music]